are you doing fantastic so let me start
by saying congrats on this movie I
thought was fantastic the best thing was
I what I really dig is just how many
times people jump in the theater watch
so did you ever go to any screenings and
like see people you know full-on jizz
jumping I did I was able to see the
movie with an audience quite a few times
and if I feel like every time that I
went there was a different moment where
people were jumping at different times
so that's usually a good sign it just
means that the film in general just has
some quality jump scares of all
completely um switching gears can just
for a second I love the leftovers thank
you okay so how do people still talk to
you about that order because for me like
that show is Damon did such a great job
with that yeah I still do get stopped
and people mention leftovers I mean that
was my first like job being in the
actors guild so that was like a huge
blessing for me at that time when I got
it and I was able to work with such a
big group of talented actors and Damon
has the craziest mind as you could see
with his with the show that he had so it
was just really cool to just to have
that be my first job and get to really
find my sea legs with that project when
you see you double your first gig what
did you learn on that set that maybe
would surprise people or maybe surprises
you about like acting because that's
obviously you know your first time doing
that kind of thing
I think that I was really lucky that
when I came on and I taking acting
courses over the years before that so I
had an idea of what I thought was the
way that you work as far I was like when
you get a job and you get a new
character how to approach it that the
director a riot would really like kind
of kind of hold your hand through it but
it was really refreshing and it was kind
of kind of I guess nerve-wracking in a
way where I had a conversation with
Damon after I had gotten cast as Michael
Murphy and I was asking him all these
questions because I had binge watched
the first season before I got the job
and I was like so how does Michael kind
of fit into the dynamic between the
garvey's and all the and he was like
Devon
all of this will start to make sense as
the scripts come out I just the way that
she played Michael in the audition room
is exactly what I felt was right so your
instincts as this character is what I
want to see for me I'm
not gonna answer those questions because
as you know the way that each episode
came out and the way that show is
written I mean it just wouldn't serve
the actors well I think for them to know
exactly what was gonna happen with these
characters I think there's a way of kind
of keeping us on our toes as well and it
kind of plays well for the audience now
jumping into overlord you you get that
script you see what this world is gonna
be how are you preparing for that role
as compared to what you did for left
overs I tried to approach it the same
way and that's just being a sincere and
truthful as possible as a character that
I'm playing I think that uh Julius and
JJ and the entire creative team they
wanted this film to be based in realism
just so that you could kind of get the
audience a sense of familiarity until we
take the rug and pull it from under them
and introduce all of the Safa elements
so as far as how to play boys I kind of
just did my research and watched a lot
of documentaries and a lot of films that
were based on this time you know the
Sabre private Ryan's and the Band of
Brothers and all of that just to be
familiar with that time of war and what
young soldiers were going through and
then I think that really helped me and
the other actors really kind of give
honest performances and when we served
well when it was time to add in all the
crazy stuff I'm always curious about
memorable moments from filming like
what's a day or two that you will always
remember from filling oh man probably
the last day of boot camp which was a
little under a week long and just going
off a lack of sleep and doing a lot of
training learning how to use all the
weapons and the equipment and the
terminology that the military was using
at that time and the very last day our
military advisor Freddie had told us
that Julius was going to come down to
kind of give us this final evaluation
based on everything that we learned why
it was going to have to be for it so
he's gonna have to get us through like a
live exercise with you know the dummy
rounds for the weapons and everything
like that and there would evaluate us
and so we were training all day
preparing for this moment it's like the
sun's starting to set it's getting into
night time and Julius shows up with like
this huge cooler cooler full of beer and
like all of our favorite snacks and
stuff like that and it just ended up
being like just like a bro like a frat
boy night
but in the middle of the woods it was
awesome because everybody got like
really just really drunk and just had a
really good time and it was cool and it
was a great way to end a really tough
boot camp it was a great way to end it
I love the opening of this movie when
you're on the plane I dive in it's super
intense I'm curious what it was like
filming that sequence and was it is what
did it have like a serious energy onset
when you're trying to capture something
like that or was it like a lot of joking
around
I think the joking was used as a device
to keep everybody high in spirits
because filming that was really
difficult I don't know if you know but
like outside of all the stuff in the
plane all that stuff was CGI but
everything that happened in the plane
was practical they had an actual c-47
remade and it was put on this hydraulic
rig and so every time the plane dipped
or shifted or shook or anything like
that it was actually happening and you
got 30 guys who aren't all small we're
all kind of packed into this into this
thing and it's suspended in the air and
all the sparks all the flames everything
that's coming out those are real so as
guys are tumbling out they're having to
be covered in you know petroleum jelly
so they're not burning and everything
that we're doing in that scene is
choreographed and if it's not done right
somebody could get hurt
so because of that everybody has to be
completely aware and just prepared and
know exactly where they need to be so
that brings about stress
so the jokes were kind of just to keep
everybody in a good mood because after
six hours of doing that for like a week
long which is how long that exchange was
people can get really you know amped and
kind of wired up and kind of snap so we
got through it and the final result was
great but it was an exercise for sure
when you were reading the script you're
getting ready to make the movie was that
the sequence or which sequence were you
reading on the page like oh [ __ ] this is
gonna be a total it wasn't saying that
one and the one that happened in in the
field like the with the with the mind I
think the minefield was like another one
that I read and I was like hmm I wonder
how that's gonna happen and then when we
filmed it it was like oh [ __ ] this is
insane
as I remember me and Jonathan Megara who
plays I'm Jonathan John Magaro who plays
today we got hay fever really bad the
day before we shot that scene so I was
like
SiC I don't know if we've ever seen
hitch but like one little Smith's face
like blew up and he had to take all that
coffee medicine that's exactly what I
looked like it was terrifying I thought
I was good but when it was you know I
took my medicine came back the next day
and we shot that scene and it was like
the exposes that they used for that was
just so intense and it was all real so
it was really easy to kind of fall into
the the atmosphere and the truth of what
the characters are going through because
the effects were loud and it was smoke
everywhere and dirt and it was just but
it was fun it was like getting to play
you're starring on your own video game
so it was really cool completely you're
six years old again exactly except it's
all real before I run out of time with
you I really enjoy Jack Ryan season one
and I believe you're in season two yes
oh can you tease anything or what can
you say about the second season I know
that it's it was incredibly difficult to
shoot we were in Colombia for three
months and it's really intense I was a
fan of the first season as well and just
coming in and getting to play Marcos is
who I'm playing as a former SEAL and
getting to play him and kind of interact
with with Jack and the other guys in the
show it was a lot of fun so I think when
it comes out I think people will really
enjoy it and it'll further you know push
the the events of the first season and
kind of really challenge challenge
audiences for sure yeah I'm also curious
like what were the scripts like when
you're reading those things are you like
oh like what's your reaction when you
first started reading it I was excited I
was like man these these guys are so
badass man everything that they do every
episode is this it's really intense and
and these guys are some of the toughest
guys on the planet so it was cool to
kind of just get to play a character
that stands with them and he goes
through his own little journey and in
this season but it's cool that
throughout the season he kind of has
moments with with Jack Ryan and the rest
of the guy the gang as well so jumping
into something a little more serious you
also I mean it's pretty crazy how many
projects your job but you're also doing
Central Perk yeah absolutely
but Central Perk five yes which is
another thing I cannot wait to see what
was it like making that and are you
still making it we finished in November
they started in August but I had to
finish that Ryan and I just flew from
Columbia straight to New York and yeah
it was tough man I was quite a
once right there but uh but Ava I mean
these separate projects I think she
really excels that she excels at
everything but these are the type of
projects that she really like in a sink
her teeth into and she gets excited
about so it was a big cast so that can
be really intimidating in itself but I
mean everybody was really warm and
everybody knew that they were there to
do a job and to be as truthful and
really represent these people who are
real people the best that they could and
I think that everyone did that really
well and they did with grace and they
did it with with confidence so I'm
excited to see the end result I think it
comes up sometime this year so I know
she's working on it
crazily right now so she's doing her
thing is it one of those things when
you're reading the scripts as an
audience you're going to be frustrated
that these things are happening to these
people I think so cuz I think there are
still a lot of people who don't know
about it so this will be an eye-opener
for a lot of people especially for a lot
of the people in this story that are
still alive and well in our living and
you know trying to recover from that
moment still so I think it'll be quite
an experience when it does come out and
I'm excited to see the the reception of
it my last thing cuz I gotta go oh now
that you've done about 16 projects here
on what's coming up for you next just
looking for the next thing I have the
second season of I'm sorry for you lost
the show that I did with Elizabeth Olsen
that we will start that later this year
I think maybe like midsummer something
like that and uh just looking for more
projects that are exciting man there's a
lot of material out there and it's a
great time for original content so I'm
just I'm looking for the next thing that
they're really excited me and just
trying to get better with these job
you